but we begin here this morning with the
news breaking overnight a string of
deadly storms that swept across the
southeast at least 24 people were killed
in Mississippi when a tornado touched
down just after Sundown Mississippi's
Governor says search and rescue
operations are underway and that
emergency crews are surging to the
area's hardest hit by the storm but
getting a clear picture of just how
damaging the storm is won't come until
daylight the system marched through
Louisiana through Mississippi and into
Alabama delivering Twisters huge
hailstones heavy rain and damaging wind
gusts the storms are stretching into the
Midwest this morning and could cause
problems from the Ohio Valley and the
Great Lakes up into the Northeast Omar
villafranca is in Silver City
Mississippi with the very latest Omar
good morning
good morning Jeff we knew that we were
getting close to where the tornado hit
because it was getting pitch black and
many of the communities where the
tornado did hit they are without power
we brought generators so you're able to
see what we are able to see and this is
what we're seeing homes like this behind
me here missing their roof just next to
it cars have been spun around and wood
smashed through the vehicles we're
starting to see downed trees power lines
that are splintered and we're expecting
it to get much worse when the sun comes
up
just before eight o'clock Friday night a
storm system ripped through Mississippi
producing a tornado that touched down
causing catastrophic damage to
communities across the state
in Rolling Fork Mississippi around 60
miles Northwest of Jackson what were
once buildings are now piles of
scattered debris The Twister moved
Northeast devastating other rural
communities officials are pleading for
help we got a multiple home damage we
got people not accounted for at the time
probably tomorrow we have a full count
on the damage and the people that's not
in place like every trailer in this town
gone Roger Cummings says his nephew was
killed in the storm Cummings rushed back
to Silver City after he heard the news
they said stayed on the ground for 47
miles
rolled up all the way through here
forecasters have been warning about this
outbreak of severe weather for days even
launching a weather balloon on Friday
everything seems to be coming together
in this location this evening for a
potential outbreak of severe weather the
deadly Twisters come on the heels of
damaging storms on Thursday and Friday
in southern Missouri a car with six
teenagers inside was Swept Away by flood
waters two did not survive and at least
two tornadoes swept through North Texas
Friday morning with Winds of 100 miles
per hour Eric Huntley dug through what
was left of his home as soon as I got
the alert
I went to go look outside and then I
heard the moan
and I'll never forget that soon
at last check around 16 000 customers
are without power but the main concern
is finding the victims and the survivors
and people who need help and trying to
get it to them but of course as we've
mentioned before we won't have a better
picture of what this looks like until
the sun comes up but it's not good Dana
all right Omar thank you very much for
your work there